le nouveau film de Costa-Gavras consacré
au silence du pape Pie XI du monde
occidental face à l'extermination des
Juifs pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
nous en parlerons tout à l'heure avec
Costa Gavras qui comme vous a choisi
tout mon en parle pour s'exprimer et je
vous en remercie voilà alors à part ça
vous triomphez dans Amélie Poulain
favori au César nommé dans cinq
catégories aux Oscars quand vous avez
reçu le scénario vous avez compris tout
de suite que ça serait un triomphe ah
non c'est pas on sait jamais si c'est un
triomphe mais on sait que ça va être un
bon film vous avez envie de le faire
tout de suite ouais pour le scénario et
pour Jean-Pierre Vasseur on vous verra
cette année dans un film tourné en l'an
2000 qui s'appelle birthday girl de Jess
better worth avec Vincent Cassel ben
Chaplin et Nicole Kidman c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune Russe qui est
venue en Grande-Bretagne pour épouser un
homme qu'elle a connu par par internet
et il y a deux tueurs dans le film c'est
vous et Vincent Cassel Nicole Kidman ça
s'est passé comment très très bien
c'était
le poste divorce donc c'était très bien
et c'était agréable parce qu'elle
travaillait il travaillait là-bas on a
tourné en Australie parce que son mari
travaillait sur Mission Impossible 2 et
donc c'était amusant de de d'être au
courant des rumeurs de tout ce qui se
passait sur le tournage de John wood qui
est quand même un metteur en scène aussi
important
comment elle est sympa dans la vie oui
non c'est Vincent bien sûr
mais c'est à chaque fois c'est la même
chose j'en ai marre
alors Mathieu Costa-Gavras donc amen
Amélie Poulain le film avec Nicole
Kidman vous êtes un homme comblé et
d'ailleurs le magazine news week le
grand magazine américain vous a choisi
comme l'une des 7 personnalités qui
dessineront le futur alors il y a des
gens incroyables il y a le futur
président de la Chine enfin il y a des
types et des femmes extraordinaires vous
savez ce que ça mérite ça quand même
j'aime beaucoup c'est gentil non mais
vraiment j'aime beaucoup alors j'ose pas
vous le dire mais j'ai quand même vous
le dire dans la vie bon vous êtes bien
mais quand vous êtes dans un film il y a
quelque chose de surnaturel c'est sans
doute la photo génie ce qu'on appelle
les visages angulaire ah bon qui
accroche bien la lumière ah oui ça vous
accrochez bien vous êtes mais vraiment
en curé dans le film que ça ira vous
êtes génial non ça passe mais c'est les
rôles et puis ça dépend aussi bien sûr
des metteurs en scène et la façon il
vous filmez bien filmer aussi sans doute
alors on va voir Mathieu Kassovitz
comment vous en êtes arrivé là et puis
d'abord d'où vous venez alors votre père
réalisateur c'est le réalisateur Peter
kasovitz dans le dernier film Jacob le
menteur avec Robin Williams ce qui est
pas rien alors votre père a quitté la
Hongrie en 56 au moment de
l'intervention soviétique à Budapest
pour s'installer à Paris et lui fils
d'ouvriers c'est rapidement intégré dans
le milieu intellectuel de
Saint-Germain-des-Prés c'était un des
intérêts de venir en France à l'époque
pour tous les tous les sur tous les gens
les pays de l'Est ou qui vivaient sous
une dictature c'était devenir en France
et de rencontrer des intellectuels
français qui à l'époque était pululées
sur les à Saint-Germain-des-Prés à
l'époque Jean-Paul Sartre qui prenait
son café on pourrait lui parler assez
facilement ce qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui merci alors après il a fait
mai 68 votre père et alors votre mère
votre mère est honteuse et vous avez
déclaré j'ai toujours vécu au milieu des
rembobineuses et des bobines si mes
parents avaient été boulanger j'aurais
été boulanger mais comme ils étaient
dans le cinéma je suis dans dans le
cinéma je suis venu cinéaste forcément
le cinéma est venu naturellement oui ça
fait partie du plaisir de découvrir des
films et de et de pouvoir en plus les
analyser mais c'est comme quand on est
pâtissier de découvrir un gâteau et puis
de commencer à analyser comment c'est
fait la même chose et puis votre père
avait eu très rapidement un minitoscope
à l'époque où c'était rare et alors là
vous avez vraiment appris ce qui vous
montrez des films et puis vous expliquer
comment ça se fabriquer c'était la
première fois on pouvait voir des films
et les arrêter revenir étudier quoi donc
vous avez appris le cinéma en fait
vraiment par apprentissage d'une façon
très Pierrick vous êtes un autodidacte
en fait de la fabrication des films de
pain théoriciens je suis ouais ouais
ouais oui oui j'ai jamais été bon à
l'école donc j'ai eu du pot de pouvoir
faire un métier qui nécessitait pas de
diplôme
vous avez pas fait du deck vous avez pas
fait la féministe rien du tout et alors
à partir de là mais vous allez essayer
d'entrer dans le cinéma par tous les
moyens possibles acteurs d'abord avec
votre père vous jouez dans un film qui
s'appelle au bout du bout du banc avec
Jane Birkin et même dans une mini-série
consacrée à Berlioz non non mais c'est
des trucs qu'on fait quand on est enfant
et j'ai fait Berlioz quand j'étais jeune
et bon c'est dur parce que ça se passe
avec des collants et avec une perruque
je me suis toujours très difficile à
assumer
ce soir de Mathieu Kassovitz en jaune
avec des collants une perruque et un
phone et puis alors dans le fondé c'est
toujours le même c'est un vrai
alors vous entendez aussi dans le cinéma
par la réalisation vous êtes très très
précoce un délage de 12-13 ans faites
des films d'horreur très gore près des
mannequins mettaient du sang dedans vous
les voyez on avait des ben on était
c'était l'époque de zombie et de tous
ces magnifiques films les Dialo italiens
et voilà et on essaie de faire la même
chose à la maison hein film de Romero
darjento
et on avait un manuel qui était qui
était écrit par un spécialiste des
effets spéciaux italiens américains et
on faisait on essaie de faire la même
chose que comme ça marchait jamais vous
avez 34 ans ça fait quand même 22 ans au
fait du cinéma
mais je parle que j'ai rencontré Jodie
Foster qui a 33 ans avait 30 ans de
carrière
alors vous essayez même d'être critique
de cinéma ou collaborez à des fanzines
vers l'âge de 15 saisons de persuadé que
c'est pas un grand critique
donc j'ai pris la conscience du travail
de critique c'était pas le mien vous
aimez pas trop les critiques
je j'ai toujours un problème des gens
qui vivent sur le sur le travail des
autres mais ça c'est après il y a des
bonnes critiques les gens qui sont
intelligents j'ai toujours j'aime les
gens intelligents mais ce n'est pas
parce qu'on est critique qu'on est
forcément intelligent malheureusement
vous dites que par exemple la critique
qui se réveille de mauvais poils
au lieu de deux ou deux trois c'est sûr
c'est que c'est tellement subjectif moi
j'aime bien cette phrase j'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de la dire mais c'est vrai il
est les avis c'est comme les trous du
cul
donc c'est bien de pouvoir s'exprimer et
bien mais il faut pas non plus être trop
indicatif et puis le choix de ses choix
personnels il faut pas les imposer aux
autres votre père lui donc quand il est
arrivé à Paris en arrivant de Hongrie il
est arrivé à s'intégrer dans le milieu
intello et vous c'est en réaction sans
doute vous êtes devenu Punk en 77
vous traînez au Halles ouais entraîner
de la valster en prenant du fringale
à sortir la Scala pour chercher
très bien il y a eu l'époque Pâques
après il y a eu l'époque rap
[Musique]
vous voyez le dernier combat le premier
long métrage de Luc Besson en noir et
blanc en scope noir et blanc et alors
jusque là vous aviez envie de faire du
cinéma et ce jour-là vous décidez d'en
faire parce que la sortie du film votre
père vous dites le mec qui a fait ça il
a 23 ans ouais ouais c'était un moment
important parce que on était à cette
époque du cinéma dans le cinéma français
on était encore sur des régimes très
très presque draconien il fallait être
premier assistant avant d'être
réalisateur il y avait une espèce de le
CNC il y a une grosse machine
de cursus qu'on les suivre et lui il a
tout cassé en arrivant et en faisant ça
un film qui était en plus un film de
science-fiction ce qui était très
important pour l'époque et pour nous
puisque il y avait pas du tout ce genre
n'était absolument pas représenté en
France alors voilà à l'époque j'ai 17
ans vous dites c'est bon j'arrête
l'école ouais ben c'était à cette époque
là je me suis rendu compte que c'était
vraiment patient j'ai pas besoin de
faire de d'école pour j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir mon bac donc j'avais l'Opportun
commencé à travailler en tant que
stagiaire sur des films je suis parti
vous avez jamais regretté ça d'avoir été
l'école
je suis tout le temps qu'on me demande
en tant que les gens qui veulent faire
du cinéma qu'est-ce que je peux faire du
cinéma voilà on fait du cinéma
aujourd'hui il y a les caméras TV qui
permettent de faire des petits films des
grands films mais absolument magnifique
et puis être présent sur un tournage
comme grouillot c'est le c'est là où on
apprend le plus bah oui c'est ça c'est à
dire que vous êtes rentré dans une boîte
de prod et puis vous avez franchi tous
les échelons en parfait autodidacte du
cinéma alors stagiaire évidemment quand
on bloque une rue et qu'on a la journée
à bloquer une rue en étant observer ça
fait que après quand je suis réalisateur
je sais que quand je prends une décision
de faire un plan dans une rue qu'il faut
bloquer toute la rue sur 200 mètres et
qu'après je me dis ah non c'est pas
grave je me mette là c'est une heure de
déplacement c'est un problème énorme et
que je perds du temps donc c'est très
important de connaître l'infrastructure
d'un tournage pour pouvoir être efficace
en temps alors en 90 vous faites votre
premier court-métrage Fiero le pou
inspirait évidemment de le fou enfin au
moins pour le titre alors un
court-métrage autofinancé vous cassez
votre tirelire 20000 balles comment vous
les aviez eu ces 20.000 balles ben
j'étais stagiaire sur des films
ça ressort ce qui fait qu'on pouvait
faire que des plans qui duraient 30
secondes parce qu'on remonter là c'est
ça les caméras c'est les 5 caméras qui
ont servi pendant la guerre des caméras
16 où il y avait pas besoin
d'électricité qui sont qui sont qui
fonctionnent d'une façon mécanique où tu
remontes la caméra ça fait un plan de 30
secondes et si on va faire un plan d'une
minute on peut pas non
quoi non mais c'est pas mal ça c'est les
contraintes techniques qui permettent
aussi d'inventer les films et les
meilleurs films ne sont pas de pure vue
d'artistes ce sont des problèmes des
gens qui sont affrontés à des problèmes
et qui ont réussi à trouver des
solutions alors votre premier
long-métrage ces trois ans plus tard
c'est métisse avec Julie moduk qui est
votre épouse aujourd'hui Lola dans le
film en 95 vous explosez avec la haine
pris de la mise en scène à Cannes de
César succès international
marionnettes au Guignols
pas longtemps pas longtemps
et qu'ils avaient adapté
j'étais stagiaire au Guignols
en 97 assassin avec un S pas comme le
cours il y avait pas d'Este avec Michel
Serrault le film soulève une tempête
extraordinaire à Cannes c'était fait
pour bras d'honneur et tout là et vous
dites c'est celui dont je suis le plus
fier c'est de la provocation vous le
pensez vraiment moi j'ai eu la chance de
faire d'avoir un succès et après en
faisant la haine après je vais deux
choix soit je me rangeais des camions et
je continuais je faisais la N2
propositions c'était toujours c'était la
possibilité et puis après ou sinon
c'était faire un dernier film où j'avais
vraiment ce que j'avais à dire puis
surtout pas en réaction par rapport à la
haine et j'ai fait à sa 5 et un film
extrêmement violent je suis content
d'avoir fait à cette époque je pourrais
plus le faire aujourd'hui alors là vous
partez deux ans aux États-Unis pour voir
un peu comment ça se passe j'ai
travaillé sur les projets avec des
superstars que j'ai jamais vu et au bout
d'un moment j'en ai marre je me suis
soit je reste soit je retourne en France
et je fais ce que j'ai envie en France
je suis revenu et puis on m'a appelé on
m'a dit tiens tu veux pas faire les
rivières comme c'était un peu l'état
d'esprit que je voulais trouver aux
États-Unis c'est-à-dire faire un film de
commande que je sois pas à moi obligé de
l'inventer de le faire jusqu'au bout
parce que c'est fatiguant
j'ai dit ouais alors ce film Les
Rivières pourpre a été un succès une
arme et vous le renier non ah si si vous
le renier
c'est pas moi c'est pas mon
universelle c'est juste agréable à
regarder non non c'est parce que c'est
parce que oui mais c'est parce que je
suis un petit peu trop prétentieux ah
bon oui c'est parce que je pense que je
peux faire mieux Oui au niveau du
scénario c'est sûr c'est sûr ben il faut
vivre avec après mais c'est un film que
j'adore et je me suis pas marié à le
faire parce que c'était très dur à faire
mais j'allais je l'ai revu là encore il
passe à la télé et je me suis j'aime
vraiment la mise en scène me plaît
vraiment énormément alors on a
l'impression quand on lit un petit peu
vos déclarations quand on vous écoute en
ce moment que vous avez un peu fait le
tour des films d'ados des films de
jeunes des films clips à effets spéciaux
et que désormais vous avez envie de
faire des films à contenus des films
avec du sens non mais je grandis voilà
maintenant j'ai 34 ans
mais ça va c'est plus la même chose que
quand j'avais 25 j'ai vu beaucoup
beaucoup de films beaucoup beaucoup de
films d'action je suis plus impressionné
depuis l'arrivée du digital
maintenant rien n'est impossible alors
quand c'est utilisé pour le Seigneur des
Anneaux moi je suis absolument
époustouflé par le brio de la
technologie et du talent du metteur en
scène et son sa possibilité mais quand
c'est fait pour des pour faire vraiment
du purifier spécial ça m'intéresse pas
n'importe quel pub pour pas que la
machine à autant de Digital et d'effets
spéciaux non non mais même après c'est
les choix personnels moi je sais que je
m'ennuie à faire à faire un truc
d'action pure j'aime bien mais j'ai
préféré arriver à faire un truc d'action
à l'intérieur d'une histoire qui me qui
me prend en trip et c'est plus amusant
c'est plus amusant là le projet sur
lequel vous allez travailler celui pour
lequel vous allez entrer en écriture
pendant un an c'est un il y a du sens
vraiment je travaille en ce moment donc
je suis en plein dedans et c'est un vrai
plaisir de trouver quelque chose pour
lequel on a une véritable passion quoi
parce qu'on est tellement sur une
énergie de c'est sa vie qui est en jeu
là voilà on se pose il des problèmes de
financement pas de problème d'argent
personnel on travaille on travaille un
travail et puis après on commence à se
faire rattraper un peu par le système et
puis aujourd'hui je me dis mais je suis
même pas obligé de travailler pour être
ce que je pourrais j'ai fait Lancôme je
pourrais me reposer ne plus ne plus
bouger mais le fait de faire Lancôme
fait que je permets ou ça me permet de
travailler plus sur mes projets à moi et
ne pas faire les rivières pourpres 2 ou
Taxi 4 voilà vachement lucide je sais
pas si si je vous le dis c'est juste 34
ans aussi à un moment
j'étais bien plus con alors
parallèlement pardon je m'en souviens
parallèlement à votre carrière de
réalisateur vous menez une carrière
d'acteurs et je vous dis en commençant
le bien que je pensais de vous en tant
qu'acteur aussi alors il y a eu un film
de Jacques Audiard regarde les hommes
tombés un autre film de Jacques Audiard
Un héros très discret et puis mon homme
de Bertrand Blier puis Amélie Poulain
puis plein d'autres bien sûr et puis
amen alors vous considérez pas acteur
comme un métier vous vous dites j'ai pas
d'angoisse parce que toute façon quand
j'arrive sur le plateau contrairement à
plein d'autres acteurs moi finalement il
y a pas tellement d'en parce que c'est
pas le truc qui m'intéresse vraiment
dans la vie et ça vous donne c'est vrai
sans doute une grande décontraction oui
c'est c'est le principal c'est de pas
avoir peur le trac fait que on sait plus
on arrive ça paralyse si vous voyez les
acteurs les grands acteurs ce qu'on
admire vraiment les les brandes d'eau
les deux Niro tous ces gens là c'est des
gens qui sont sur deux c'est pour ça
qu'on les remarque quand ils arrivent
dans un endroit même de Niro qu'un petit
gars quand il arrive dans un endroit
tout le monde c'est vrai ou pas parce
que il dégage quelque chose il est sur
de lui il a rien à prouvé et à partir du
moment où tu arrives sur un tournage et
que t'as rien approuvé tout d'un coup tu
es libre alors vous dites j'ai plus
envie de faire de film en tant qu'acteur
sauf si c'est ce corset
pour dire que j'aime bien travailler
avec des metteur en scène que j'aime
donc je je voilà j'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec des metteurs en scène
vraiment et puis surtout j'ai appris ce
que j'avais à prendre je crois donc j'ai
pas besoin de continuer ça je fais des
films en tant que réalisateur ça me
prend du temps ça me prend mon énergie
Jean-Pierre Élysée qui me trouvait
admirable que j'arrive à faire trois
trucs en même temps et en fait je me
suis rendu compte que c'est plus
intéressant de faire un truc bien
alors donc vous bossez pas spécialement
pour le pognon sinon comme vous dites
vous feriez Les rivières pourpres 2 ou
la N4 vous dites le principe c'est une
phrase à méditer le principe c'est de
réussir sa vie c'est pas de devenir
milliardaire
nous on peut réussir sa vie en devenir
milliardaire c'est pas mal si c'est pour
redistribuer l'argent aussi parce que
bon après un consommation d'un
consommation d'argent qu'on peut pas
dépasser non plus
je vous dis que vous êtes sage après la
haine on vous a accusé d'avoir pris un
peu la grosse tête vous en souvenez de
ça oui oui mais c'est non tout le temps
non c'est parce que j'étais
je sais pas je sais pas parce que je
suis pas rentré dans le dans le domaine
aussi qu'on dans lequel on voulait me
faire rentrer
et puis en battant contre je suis devenu
une super starlette
non mais vous avez appris à devenir
courtois là vous êtes quand même non
mais on grandit pas j'ai eu des
réactions après la haine des réactions
qui étaient réelles j'ai vu des gens qui
m'ont dit des choses absolument à
urgentes et dangereuse pour le film moi
je me bats deux ans pour raconter une
histoire qui a un sens moi on veut pas
faire un film comme ça et se retrouver
avec ça prenait à parler banlieue dans
VSD malheureusement on n'est pas au
contrôle de ça
donc vous donnez plus courtois vous
dites on peut pas mettre des coups de
poing toute sa vie non parce que si on
tape en plus si on s'adresse à un
système comme ça aussi fort que
l'économie qui a dans le cinéma et tout
ce qu'il y a autour au niveau des médias
on tape dans un mur donc il vaut mieux
l'infiltrer d'une façon habile sournoise
et habile ou puis voir son plan faire à
l'intérieur
d'être sympa le truc c'est que il y a
aucune raison qui vous donne du blé si
déjà il ne récupère pas son blé qui n'a
pas d'épreuve comme quoi il va récupérer
son blé et en plus si vous l'insultez
pendant tout voilà donc c'est il y a
aucune raison et je comprends ça donc je
je voilà j'espère que je peux utiliser
aussi ce système d'une autre façon vous
apprenez à vivre ouais ouais bien sûr
qu'il y a une époque je me serais jamais
venu ici quoi c'est un truc qui m'aurait
fait extrêmement peur de me dire bon on
peut comme on va on a fait un film avec
Costa par exemple qui qui est
extrêmement
précis et et et pour Costa et pour moi
aussi enfin pour tous les gens qui ont
travaillé sur les films c'est c'est une
œuvre qui nous
importante la communication autour de ce
film est très très important elle peut
moi je me suis rendu compte je me suis
fait détruire ce que des choses que je
voulais dire à travers la façon dont
même moi j'ai communiqué une façon
idiote donc il faut faire attention mais
d'un autre côté il faut être vu aussi
jusqu'ici tout va bien et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu